[Music]  hello everyone and welcome to the third  annual gift comics Russian world the  world's largest protein expression on my  conference and welcome to the dimension  of time from culture to a thing they  virtually that provided a third Toria  everybody I'm Ross or sauce moment and  I'm the founder of the Pennsylvania  medical cannabis aesthetic and I'd like  to welcome you to the second annual  cannabis science is virtually met  [Music]  the mortgage lender and they versus this  year's event is produced on a new more  robust platform that allows you to watch  to learn and connect on mobile devices  during this conference and don't forget  about our event certification check out  the leader board point system where you  can move around the entire event earning  points to receive your certificate of  participation so without further ado  please enjoy our Gipp co-expression  world virtual conference thank you